merci d'être avec nous Bernard jaumier
nous accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure sénateurs de Paris à parenté
au groupe socialiste vice-président de
la commission des affaires sociales
médecin et on va beaucoup parler
justement des questions de santé à
commencer par le covid puisqu'on l'a
entendu hier lors des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement à
l'Assemblée Isabelle borne a lancé un
appel solennel à remettre le masque dans
les transports en personne dans des
présences fragiles et dans les lieux de
promiscuité est-ce que c'est suffisant
ou est-ce qu'il faut le rendre à nouveau
obligatoire non c'est pas suffisant il y
a eu 90 morts je crois hier la journée
d'hier du covid donc l'épidémie elle a
pandémie elle est toujours là même si
elle est devenue plus plus chronique
il faut prendre des mesures beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus fortes parce que la
réalité c'est que ce sont ceux qui
meurent ce sont les plus faibles on est
en train d'abandonner les plus fragiles
et moi c'est pas un modèle de société
que je que je défends alors ces appels
solennels ça n'aura pas d'impact la
réalité c'est qu'il faut freiner la
transmission et on doit changer de
culture doit s'approprier à la santé
publique on ne le fait pas assez dans
notre pays donc il serait dans l'idéal
on porterait un masque l'hiver quand on
est dans un lieu clos et bondé et encore
plus si on est enrhumé on ne le fait pas
mais je pense que il faut le rendre
obligatoire pour protéger les plus
faibles donc oui le masque dans les
lieux clos dans les lieux où il y a
beaucoup de monde obligatoire et puis ce
problème de la couverture vaccinale
qu'il a aussi beaucoup trop faible
vaccinal qui marche pas avec 6 nations
contre la grippe qui marche pas
tellement non plus comment on fait
est-ce que là il faut la rendre
obligatoire pour les publics fragiles
comment voulez-vous là aussi que ça
marche puisque personne n'y comprend
rien les gens vont tous chez leur
médecin pour demander est-ce que je dois
faire un rappel personne ne comprend au
bout de combien de temps on doit faire
un rappel c'est le premier problème le
deuxième c'est que
vous voyez des messages de communication
claire vous voyez des spots à la télé
pour vous dire voilà au bout de temps de
moi il faut faire un rappel non le
deuxième problème c'est que quand vous
regardez les taux de couverture
vaccinades dans notre pays pour les
vaccins obligatoires et Agnès Buzyn
avait eu raison des augmenter à 11 et
nous avions soutenu cette mesure-là on
atteint des taux très élevés parce que
les gens disent bon bah c'est
obligatoire je le fais et pour tous les
autres vaccins qui ne sont pas
obligatoires je pense par exemple au
vaccin contre le papillomavirus qui est
destiné à ce que les femmes n'aient plus
de cancer du col de l'utérus et ben on a
des taux extrêmement bas parce que voilà
c'est notre culture que je regrette il
faudrait dans idéal changer de culture
ce n'est pas le cas donc moi je suis
favorable à l'obligation vaccinale parce
que c'est simple c'est efficace et les
sa protège les plus faibles un mot sur
un autre débat mais qu'il y est c'est la
réintégration des personnes non
vaccinées il y a eu un débat à
l'Assemblée nationale sur ce sujet jeudi
est-ce que vous vous déplorez la manière
dont s'est déroulait ce débat
notre vie politique c'est cette
radicalisation cette brutalisation du
débat ses insultes proférées Marc notre
démocratie
oui à l'Assemblée nationale c'est très
clair et on voyait là que ceux qui
étaient opposés à la réintégration des
soignants non vaccinés avaient peur ce
théser et souvent n'ont pas participé au
vote par contre
et oui très majoritairement je le
regrette mais je constate qu'ils se sont
tues et qu'ils n'ont pas participé au
vote et pourquoi pas parce que ils
étaient favorables cette réintégration
ils y étaient opposés mais parce que la
pression physique
et et verbale des députés qui portaient
cette mesure à fausser le débat
démocratique je le dis le gouvernement a
une part de responsabilité mais cette
attitude politique là n'est pas bonne
pour notre démocratie on va continuer à
parler de ces questions de santé hier le
Sénat examiné en nouvelle lecture le
budget de la sécurité sociale passée par
49,3 à l'Assemblée nationale alors on va
voir comment ça s'est passé au
scénaristique du Jourdain
[Musique]
par le Sénat il prévoyait pourtant
davantage de moyens pour le plus
d'argent pour l'hôpital public en
nouvelle lecture les députés avaient
adopté une rallonge supplémentaire de
543 millions d'euros pour justifier
cette rallonge le gouvernement avait mis
en avant la nécessité de débloquer des
fonds en raison des coûts liés au covid
et c'est 543 millions s'ajoutent au 570
débloqué début novembre par l'exécutif
et voter ici même au Sénat l'urgence
selon le ministre de la santé était
alors de soulager l'hôpital dans un
contexte hivernal tendu entre covid
bronchiolite et épidémie de grippe il y
a le gouvernement a mis en avant
l'effort financier consenti en direction
de l'hôpital écoutez
gouvernement augmentation conséquente
s'inscrit dans la droite ligne de
l'effort d'investissement que nous avons
réalisé ces dernières années notamment
avec le Ségur de la santé
pour soutenir l'hôpital face aux
épisodes hivernaux nous ajoutons un
milliard d'euros pour l'année 2022 comme
voté au sein de cette chambre et si
pourquoi le scénario
une commission mixte paritaire avait
échoué député et sénateurs n'étaient pas
parvenus à s'entendre sur un texte
commun rappelons ce que le Sénat
proposait il demandait le recul de l'âge
de départ à la retraite à 64 ans et
proposait aussi d'augmenter la
contribution des mutuelles et d'exonérer
de cotisations retraite tous les
professionnels de santé autour de
mesures auxquelles le gouvernement a dit
non ce qui a plutôt vexé des sénateurs
écouté
madame la ministre c'est bien ce que le
Gouvernement a souhaité retenir retenir
qui nous arrive aujourd'hui
or reconnaissons que les apports du
Sénat qui figurent dans ce texte sont
particulièrement modestes aucun des
amendements les plus significatifs
adoptés par le Sénat a été retenu
maintenant rejeté ce texte il faut pas
d'enveloppe supplémentaire pour
l'hôpital
la majorité sénatoriale assez propre
raisons budget de la Sécurité sociale
c'est quoi sur l'hôpital très
précisément le budget de l'hôpital
augmente moins vite que l'inflation
quand un salarié son salaire augmente
moins vite que l'inflation et perd du
pouvoir d'achat un hôpital quand son
budget augmente moins vite que
l'inflation il perd du pouvoir de
soigner nous on n'en veut pas de ce
budget là deuxièmement les soignants de
ville leur enveloppe elle augmente
moitié moins que l'inflation alors ils
ont perdent encore plus de pouvoir de
soigner et ben un budget de la Sécurité
sociale qui alors que tous les
professionnels de santé
proteste de leur condition d'exercices
alors que l'hôpital est en tension
extrême un budget de la Sécurité sociale
qui ne donne pas les moyens aux
soignants de travailler évidemment qu'on
le rejette vous avez dit hier que le
gouvernement n'avait pas tiré tous les
enseignements de la crise du covid
pourquoi
la crise covid a montré que notre
système de santé devait se transformer
on parlait de l'épidémie de covid de la
vaccination du changement de
comportement santé publique mais il y a
le rôle des collectivités territoriales
aussi on a vu que ceux qui contribuaient
à la santé publique c'était pas non plus
que les soignants qu'est-ce qu'il y a
dans ce budget de la Sécurité sociale
qui indique ce virage dans notre système
de santé a besoin pour prendre en compte
le fait que une mairie bah oui ça un
rôle à tenir en santé que l'éducation
etc rien du tout où est le virage de la
prévention défendu à juste titre par le
ministre de la santé et la prévention
ces paroles sont très justes mais ces
axes sont inexistants il n'y a pas de
virage de la prévention dans ce budget
de la Sécurité sociale donc vous voyez
bien que il est très décevant d'ailleurs
c'est le premier budget de sécurité
sociale d'un quinquennat en général
c'est fondateurs il y a des orientations
politiques fortes là il y a la
contrainte de Bercy encore est en train
de Bercy est toujours la contrainte de
Bercy
quelle était sociale les sénateurs de
droite avaient voté le report de l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite à 64 ans
hier Elisabeth borne était devant les
députés de la majorité présidentielle et
le gouvernement maintient son calendrier
c'est-à-dire 65 ans à l'horizon 2031
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez j'en pense
que ça révèle comme d'ailleurs le budget
de la Sécurité sociale la méthode
politique du gouvernement c'est-à-dire
que les Français au mois de juin ont dit
à la classe politique
aux élus écoutez il faut que vous
employez dans une logique de compromis
personne n'a la majorité absolue le
gouvernement arrive avec son budget de
la Sécurité sociale et il balaye
absolument tous les amendements que nous
avons déposé c'est la première fois que
je vois ça depuis que je suis sénateur
avec l'outil du 49-3 c'est-à-dire au
lieu de faire un 49,3 il en a le droit
c'est la Constitution il en a besoin
mais avec du compromis dedans il fait un
49-3 brutal réforme des retraites il dit
on ouvre une discussion on commence à
discuter et là avant que la discussion
soit terminée et ben la première
ministre dit et bah ce sera ça
finalement l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite alors derrière son porte-parole
rétropédal à moitié dit oui mais non
mais peut-être mais on sait pas mais
c'est ça révèle simplement que la
demande des Français de compromis
politique le gouvernement ne l'a pas
entendu et qu'il reste dans sa démarche
dans l'absolutisme de la Cinquième
République peut-être qui est on est au
gouvernement on fait ce qu'on veut et on
ne prend pas en compte les négociations
les discussions et le débat
parlementaire voilà le résultat vous
préparez un nouveau 49-3 sur cette
réforme des retraites
je ne sais pas parce que ils peuvent il
peut y avoir un accord avec les
républicains parce que sur un certain
nombre de projets de loi on a bien vu
que le gouvernement va chercher un
accord avec les républicains parce qu'à
l'Assemblée nationale ça lui garantit
une majorité et par ailleurs ça
correspond à l'évolution la mouvance
présidentielle qui de en marche à
Renaissance dérivent vers la droite bon
donc ça je veux dire et c'est leur
responsable leur responsabilité de de
procéder cette façon là mais en tout
état de cause il n'entendent pas la
demande de compromis la demande de
changement de culture politique aussi
vous voyez qu'on a un gouvernement qui
est vraiment très conservateur dans ces
méthodes et dans son fond politique
que c'est ma poursuit l'examen du budget
et Steve hier le Sénat a voté une
réforme de l'aide médicale d'État oui
c'est une aide un qui bénéficieuse
étrangers en situation irrégulière ça
concerne environ
400000 personnes alors le montant de
cette aide a été réduit de 350 millions
d'euros par le Sénat l'objectif c'est de
ne plus couvrir que les soins
urgents et les maladies graves le
gouvernement est opposé à cette
réduction Bernard jaumier vous êtes du
côté du gouvernement et du côté du Sénat
là dessus je suis côté de la santé
publique comme d'habitude et des gens
qui ont besoin et qu'on doit soigner
vous savez c'est un débat qui revient
chaque année et chaque année le groupe
les républicains et la majorité
sénatoriale confondent la politique
migratoire avec la politique de santé
publique l'aide médicale d'État ce n'est
pas un dispositif de contrôle de la
politique migratoire c'est un autre
sujet c'est un sujet qui est légitime
pour un état pour un parlement de
débattre des contrôles migratoires mais
l'aide médicale état c'est quoi c'est un
dispositif qui dit que quand quelqu'un
n'a pas de droit à la sécurité sociale
dans notre pays on le soigne quand même
et y compris on le soigne avant qu'il
ait quelque chose de grave parce que
cette bêtise d'attendre que les gens
aient quelque chose de grave ça coûte
plus cher en plus à la collectivité donc
sauf à défendre l'idée
qu'on va pas les soigner du tout mais
sinon à part ceux qui voudraient
défendre ça mais heureusement je
n'entends personne défendre cette idée
c'est une bêtise et quand vous regardez
pourquoi le budget de l'aide médicale
d'État progresse c'est la partie
hospitalière vous savez pourquoi
regarder dans le détail c'est la partie
hospitalière parce qu'on a compliqué
avec le les
imbécile amendement et décision il y a
trois ans de restreindre l'accès à
l'aide médicale d'État mais si ça a
marché contrairement à ce qu'ils disent
c'est plus compliqué et donc et ça se
reporte sur l'hôpital les gens les soins
de ville de la me ça ne bouge pas
quasiment pas voilà donc le résultat de
tout ça c'est que ça coûte plus cher
parce que les gens vont se faire soigner
plus tard et deuxièmement on a l'état à
restreindre la délivrance de titre de
séjour quand quelqu'un est en situation
irrégulière et que vous le laissez en
situation irrégulière il relève de la me
si vous le régularisez il passe sur la
sécurité sociale comme on a moins
régularisé et ben on a laissé plus de
gens dans la même justement la droite
dit qu'il y a une contradiction très
rapidement une contradiction entre cette
volonté de restreindre les flux
l'immigration et en même temps cette
augmentation de la vous voyez aussi une
contradiction là dedans dans cette
politique vous pointez c'est exactement
ce pardon de ce que je veux pas vous
associer à mes propos mais ce que je
disais
au fond de le contrôle de la politique
migratoire avec un dispositif de santé
publique ils ont tout faux voilà à tout
à l'heure on parlera des républicains
notamment parce qu'il y a le grand débat
sur évidemment sur Public Sénat dans une
petite demi-heure maintenant
tout à l'heure on va continuer à parler
des questions de santé en attendant
c'est aussi évidemment la qualité dans
nos régions va Poitiers on retrouve
Delphine Blanchard journaliste à La
Nouvelle République bonjour Delphine
merci d'être là et Delphine vous nous
proposez un dossier sur les façons de
rompre l'isolement des personnes
résidant n'est pas
si les seniors qui habitent la commune
de Lusignan venait partager un moment de
convivialité avec les résidents de
l'EHPAD de cette même commune c'est le
pari qui a été lancé sous forme
d'ateliers à la mi-nove pour rompre
l'isolement dans cette petite commune à
30 minutes de Poitiers le nom de ce
projet recréant du lien impossible de
faire plus limpide nous avons assisté à
l'un de ces ateliers en début de semaine
quatre résidents de l'EHPAD et trois
seniors habitants à leur domicile se
sont réunis lors d'un après-midi pour
parler de leur loisirs de leurs envies
et de la façon de retrouver goût aux
sorties finalement autour d'un café
c'est surtout une façon de passer du bon
temps loin de la chambre de la résidence
ou du train-train du quotidien surtout
qu'il n'est pas si facile de faire
sortir les résidents de leur chambre
devenu refuge depuis le covid pour
certains il y a encore la peur d'être
contaminé c'est parfois une épreuve et
un premier pas vers l'extérieur
l'atelier qui se trouve dans une salle
au milieu de la cour intérieure de
l'établissement peut devenir une étape
avant d'aller jusqu'au jardin de la
résidence pour nourrir les poules par
exemple si ce sont des petits pas pour
les résidences et certainement un grand
bon pour l'autonomie j'ai une question
pour vous monsieur le sénateur
l'isolement social des seniors est-il
selon vous un enjeu de santé publique
alors d'abord merci pour votre pour
votre témoignage pour l'expérience que
vous relatez oui mais c'est au-delà d'un
enjeu de santé publique c'est un enjeu
social de façon plus générale et ça
démontre je dirais l'importance que
notre pays se penche réellement sur la
question dont la dépendance et le grand
âge son prix en charge et son vécu dans
notre pays vous savez que depuis des
années on attend une loi cadre alors
c'est pas pour le fétiche d'une loi 4
mais c'est parce qu'on en a besoin pour
poser des grands principes pour poser
ces cadres le domicile l'EPAD
comment comment on fait pour que les
personnes puissent choisir pour que
celles qui veuille rester à domicile et
des dispositifs adaptés pour que celles
qui sont en EHPAD bénéficient dans ces
ehpad de cette qualité de prise en
charge qui va au-delà des fonctions
essentielles on va dire et
physiologiques et qui est cette prise en
compte des activités du respect du
rythme de la personne âgée du maintien
de ses liens sociaux mais familier aussi
parler d'épidémie de covid on a on a
encore des réactions qui sont des
réactions de fermeture qui ne sont pas
justifiées qui ne faut pas il faut pas
aller dans cette direction là et
malheureusement vous voyez on vient de
discuter du budget de la Sécurité
sociale comme vous le savez maintenant
l'autonomie est une branche c'est la
cinquième branche de la sécurité sociale
et on n'a pas eu de discussion au fond
sur cette question parce qu'on a
toujours pas cette loi alors vous savez
qu'un dispositif de deux heures en ville
pour favoriser le lien social a été
adopté c'est très bien mais il est
vraiment urgent que on vers un cadre qui
soit plus satisfaisant et
malheureusement bon le printemps dernier
a révélé qu'un certain nombre d'EHPAD
abusent plus créatifs avaient des
pratiques qui qui racontent quelque
chose c'est que des gens préfèrent
utiliser le grand âge pour ouvrir des
établissements à but lucratif et moi je
trouve que c'est choquant et je trouve
que il faut qu'on utilise les moyens de
la collectivité les financements que
l'on met à améliorer la qualité de vie
et la qualité le lien social des
personnes qui sont dans des
établissements c'est bien sûr une
question de santé mais au-delà une
question de respect qu'on doit aux
personnes
âgées
on va parler d'un autre sujet avec vous
toujours dans le domaine de la santé
c'est cette grève des médecins libéraux
annoncés pour demain et vendredi oui la
mobilisation sera-t-elle importante
c'est vraiment la question du préavis
qui est pour jeudi 1er décembre et
vendredi 2 décembre c'est un préavis de
grève nationale qui a été déposé par le
groupe facebook médecin pour demain fort
de 44000 14000 membres excusez-moi suivi
malgré tout par de nombreux syndicats
leur doléances sont assez simples les
médecins sont usés avec pas après trois
années de covid on en parlait à
l'instant il souffre aussi d'un manque
de reconnaissance la surcharge de
travail est trop conséquente les burn
out se multiplient parmi les
revendications il y a notamment la
quatrième année d'internat sans
obligation d'aller dans un désert
médical ou encore passer la consultation
à 50 euros à Châtellerault par exemple
dans la Vienne le cabinet médical
n'assure aucun rendez-vous durant les
deux prochains jours dans un territoire
où il est déjà très très compliqué
d'avoir accès à la médecine libérale
selon vous monsieur le sénateur cette
grève est-elle justifiée du côté des
patients elle est vraiment pas très très
bien comprise je vous l'avoue alors
d'abord moi je note que très souvent
quand les soignants disent qu'ils font
grève c'est un affichage mais qu'ils
assurent regardez les infirmières à
l'hôpital en grève ça se traduit par un
autocollant mis sur la blouse et des
infirmières qui continuent à travailler
c'est la même chose pour les médecins
non ce qu'il faut entendre vous savez
hier c'était les psychiatres qui étaient
en grève et qui manifestait ça va être
les médecins généralistes demain
après-demain les infirmières c'est
récurrent aussi les professionnels de
santé que ce soit à l'hôpital ou en
ville exprime une souffrance exprime une
tension et la question c'est qu'est-ce
que notre pays consacre à son système de
santé on pourrait dire aussi sur la
justice etc ce que je ce qu'on peut
constater c'est que ces services sont
des services publics même si parfois ils
ont une forme privée dans l'exécution
mais c'est du financement par la
Sécurité Sociale donc public en France
nous ne finançons plus les services
publics c'est le paradoxe de notre pays
qui a des
dépenses publiques qui a progressé en
vingt ans maintenant 55% du PIB mais
dans il faut comprendre que dans la
dépense publique le financement des
services publics a baissé et qu'on ne
finance pas plus nos services publics il
y a 40 ans alors qu'on a 15 millions
d'habitants en plus et c'est pour ça que
la justice ne fonctionne plus que les
l'éducation est en difficulté et que le
monde de la santé est en difficulté il
faudra qu'un jour on est ce débat au
fond dans notre pays à quoi sert la
dépense publique et en deux mots
maintenant nous consacrons plus de
moyens à financer des exonérations de
cotisation à financer ce qu'on appelle
du transfert vers les entreprises ou
vers les ménages et l'État ne finance
plus ces services publics dont vous avez
l'ensemble des soignants qui sont en
déshérence qui sont en grande difficulté
alors si on leur en prenant un bâton et
en tapant sur la tête vous savez ce qui
va se passer c'est très simple ils vont
arrêter c'est les infirmières qui
quittent l'hôpital c'est des étudiants
en médecine chez lesquels le taux de
suicide est largement plus élevé que
dans la moyenne de la population et qui
sont en souffrance et à qui on dit on va
en plus vous imposer de nouvelles
contraintes non on prend le problème à
l'envers il faut que notre pays financer
service public financent ces fonctions
essentielles et respectent ceux qui sont
en première ligne merci Delphine merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous la Une de
La Nouvelle République c'est grand
Châtellerault l'énergie flambe c'est à
la Une de votre journal un mot Bernard
jaumier sur l'actualité dans votre
région Île-de-France et cette question
des transports du financement des
transports Valérie Pécresse qui dit que
s'il n'y a pas d'aide le passe Navigo de
augmenter pour les usagers est-ce que
pour vous elle a raison de demander une
hausse de la contribution des
entreprises
ah mais moi je partage encore une fois
le fait que voilà encore une fonction
essentielle un service public qui en
état de sous-financement chronique donc
maintenant Valérie Pécresse se retrouve
comme tout les grands-mères comme tous
les présidents de métropole etc en
difficulté avec un état qui est aux
abonnés absents donc avec
un ministre des Transports qui ne répond
pas clément Beaune et qui ne financent
pas à hauteur les transports en commun
dans notre pays donc on peut toujours
annoncer qu'on va faire 10 RER dans les
grandes métropoles ça c'est vraiment un
exercice de communication totalement
déconnectée de la réalité de ces
territoires et donc la responsabilité de
gouvernement merci Bernard jaumier merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin dans 20 minutes à 3 jours du
premier tour de la présidence des
républicains grands débat entre les
représentants des trois candidats de
sénateurs Stéphane lerudulier pour Bruno
Retailleau Alain jouyandet pour Éric
Ciotti et le député Raphaël berger qui
représente Aurélien Pradier ce sera à
suivre dans 20 minutes mais d'abord vous
allez laisser votre place à notre
prochaine